we've traveled south of the city of
zapporia the road behind me is the road
that it was expected perhaps
optimistically to see buses of civilians
being transported out of mariopol taking
them north to zapariza that didn't
happen because the ceasefire failed
the road has been very quiet we've seen
the occasional
car carrying children
north we've also seen a lot of military
interestingly checkpoints that we've
seen earlier in the day now abandoned
and ukrainian tanks heading towards
russian positions we've been told are
only around 20 kilometers south of here
we've been speaking to villagers
in this area they tell us that the
situation has deteriorated dramatically
today
this group of people said they had never
heard shelling as intense
our parents always said we were born
during the war with the nazis and we
would die during a war i hope the soil
rejects putin's dead body how is it
possible they are our next of kin how
can they do this my relatives are in
russia we have their blood and they have
ours
there's no electricity we have no idea
what's going on around us my son is
fighting in donbass i haven't heard from
him for four days i don't even know if
he's still alive
[Music]
the owner of this car says a shell
destroyed its wheel as he tried to drive
his family to safety
it hit here and smashed the wheel the
russians are shelling even though they
saw cars with signs saying children
inside
driving back north to zaparisia the
roads were quiet ukrainian tanks headed
south charles stratford al jazeera near
zapposia eastern ukraine